et notre invité politique ce matin cette
attaque atteint ce bonjour merci
beaucoup brésil avec nos coordinateur de
la france un sur dix porte parole du
candidat jean luc mélenchon on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représenté par jefferson des
sports de sud-ouest bonjour de faire
salle bonjour oriane bon joueur de
hockey et on va commencer en parlant de
l'ukraine évidemment adrien catelet
vladimir poutine qui fait pression sur
les occidentaux les russes veulent que
le gaz soit payée dès aujourd'hui on
roubles refus de la france et de
l'allemagne qui continueront à payer en
euros et en dollars bruno le maire a
t-il raison de ne pas céder ah bah oui
dans la mesure où je crois que les
contrats ont été signés dans une devise
c'est ne pas respecter les contraintes
de la faire signer dans une autre
normalement on paye des contrats dans la
devise que soit le fournisseur sauf que
là en l'espèce les contrats avaient été
signés avec une devise il admire poutine
en réclame une autre bref que se
passe-t-il c'est la guerre et donc la
dîmière poussines essaye de de préserver
le rouble et de frapper le dollar et
c'est la raison pour laquelle voyez ça
me permet de faire le lien avec une
proposition de notre programme à
laquelle je pense c'est que nous nous
proposons par exemple pour les échanges
commerciaux internationaux il ya une
monnaie commune c'était une
revendication de l'altermondialisme pour
éviter justement que les monnaies des
uns et des autres ne serve d'instrument
de pression géopolitique
voilà ensuite s'agissant du gaz écouter
faut qu'il faut regarder ça avec
précision parce que quand on a entendu
parler de l'embargo sur le gaz russe on
peut se dire qu'à priori ça tombe sous
le sens la vérité c'est que on refuse
d'un côté le gaz russe mais par contre
le gaz américain qui est du gaz de
schiste qui lui du coût est extrêmement
rentable dans la période parce qu'il est
rentable à 60 dollars le baril et
maintenant il en coût de 115 celui-ci
vaudrait mieux bon je pense qu'elle va
très vite non je ne crois pas je pense
que pour sanctionner efficacement la
dîmière poutine il faut frapper durement
les oligarques autour de lui davantage
que de faire des sanctions tous azimuts
qui non seulement ont pour effet un
peut-être de solidifier le peuple russe
avec le personnage qui a choisi la
guerre c'est détestable de pousser sans
doute les russes dans les bras des
chinois ce à quoi nous n'avons pas grand
intérêt j'ai vu que les chinois avaient
déclaré qu'ils investiraient eux dans
tous les secteurs économiques sanctionné
et al'inverse nous avons en effet besoin
de garantir notre notre fourniture par
contre les oligarques autour de vladimir
poutine pour l'isoler lui du pouvoir qui
l'entourent et faire en sorte qu'ils
reviennent à la table des discussions ça
c'est une nécessité par contre assez
loin c'est ce pas les sanctions sur les
sanctions sur les oligarques en tout cas
ne vont pas assez loin quand je vois
qu'on a juste attrapé un yacht à la
ciotat en réalité il ya beaucoup à faire
et y compris
oui mais par exemple l'argent des
oligarques russes se trouvent beaucoup
dans les paradis fiscaux européens et il
se trouve que le pouvoir en place en
france n'y est pas pour rien puisque
souvenez vous que c'est monsieur macron
lui-même qui avait fait en sorte que on
retire un certain nombre de pays
européens de la liste des paradis
fiscaux européens parce que évidemment
il ya des oligarques russes mais pas que
nous avons aussi les nôtres et donc
l'argent de beaucoup de liga recrues se
trouvent dans ces paradis fait j'espère
donc je reviens sur le gaz russe parce
que j'ai pas bien compris pourquoi j'ai
repris très dépendants du gaz de schiste
américain mais qu'est ce que fait jean
luc mélenchon s'il est à la place
d'emmanuel macro avec un vladimir
poutine qui refuse qu'on lui paye son
gaz enroulé on fait quoi du coup non
mais là en l'espèce il ya la question
des contrats qui ont été signés si le
contrat qui a été signalée sage et bien
compris mais voilà ton art est
d'importer le gaz aujourd'hui on arrête
d'en porter le gaz de russie voulait
dire non on peut pas faire ça si on m'a
fait ben non c'est en lots en l'espèce
c'est le délire poutine qui respecte pas
sa part du contrat normalement oui la
règle c'est que c'est le fournisseur qui
décide de la devise dans laquelle on
paye sauf que là il ya des contrats qui
ont été signés donc en effet c'est un
rapport de force mais elle pour le coup
c'est vladimir
par la diplomatie n'est de toute façon
quelle autre solution savez dans cette
dans cette situation une craignait
évidemment que l'intuition première
quand on voit des femmes des hommes sous
les bombes un vladimir poutine qui alors
qu'il se dit prêt à discuter continuent
de bombarder kiev c'est absolument
intolérable on se dit la première chose
c'est de les aider mais faut voir
précisément que fait-on et poumons le
foie comme bruno le maire on se prépare
à arrêter les importations de gaz russe
pour vous ce n'est pas la seule région
que c'est une solution dans l'arsenal
mais pour faire quoi pour lui préférer
le gaz de schiste américain très
franchement la question mérite d'être
posée je reste sur l'ukraine adrien cnas
jean luc mélenchon veut sortir la france
du commandement intégré de l'otan or
face à la guerre en ukraine c'est bien
une réponse de l'otan qui se dessine sur
flanc est que pourrait faire la france
tout seul sans aide dans le secondaire
intégré de l'otan parce que là c'est une
réponse des alliés qui était proposé
d'avoir fort à voir à plusieurs d'abord
voir une chose sur la situation telle
que nous l'avons sous les yeux elle est
aussi le fruit de nombreuses années
d'erreurs je rappelle que jean luc
mélenchon ça fait plus de dix ans que
sur à peu près tous les plateaux télé
avec parfois des gens qui se posait la
question de savoir pourquoi il parlait
ça il dit l'écouté la question des
frontières en europe depuis l'implosion
du bloc soviétique elle pose de
nombreuses tensions dans une dizaine
d'endroits
non pas que jean luc mélenchon lui est
envie de discuter des frontières mais il
dit les frontières sont en cause dans un
certain nombre d'endroits soir on ne
fait rien et vous prenez le risque
d'avoir des conflit qui s'envenime
ce qu'on a sous nos yeux aujourd'hui
soit on en parle dans un cadre
diplomatique il proposait pendant
longtemps une conférence internationale
des frontières première chose ça fait
dix ans qu'il le dit la deuxième chose
alors évidemment que comme aujourd'hui
vladimir poutine seul a choisi la guerre
c'est lui qui a choisi de faire la
guerre donc c'est lui que nous
condamnons parce qu'il viole le droit
international et c'est absolument
insupportable
néanmoins si on s'empêche d'avoir une
analyse géopolitique qui consiste à dire
que la volonté des américains détendre
toujours plus à l'est le cadre de l'otan
a contribué à la situation qu'on a sous
les yeux alors on se prive d'une analyse
géopolitique
complète oui la question de l'otan est
posée d'ailleurs je me demande ce matin
ce qu'ont à dire toutes celles et ceux
qui nous ont beaucoup critiqué sur le
thème l'otan n'est pas le sujet alors
que précisément l'otan est au coeur des
discussions des négociations qui sont en
cours pour un accord de paix
expliquez-moi donc pourquoi nous serions
hors sujet alors que précisément autour
de la table aujourd'hui entre ukrainiens
et russes c'est de la question de la
neutralité souverain qu'ont décidé de
prendre cette alliance mais a beaucoup
de sujets aussi a bien sûr qu'est des
pays souverains évidemment mais ne pas
voir que les états unis d'amérique
puissance déclinante sur le front
économique face à la chine choisit de et
pensez toujours plus militairement
l'otan c'est 1000 31 milliards de
dépenses militaires pour ces tendres
toujours plus à l'est et que ceci a été
un des ingrédients pas le seul mais un
des ingrédients qui a poussé à la
situation qu'on a sous les yeux très
franchement c'est se priver d'une
analyse entièrement fondées mais ce
qu'il faut se rappeler pour résumer
c'est que pour concourir à la paix la
paix c'est pas un état de fait qui se
constatent alors on se lève pas un matin
en disant c'est la paix la paix ça se
construit politiquement et la question
effectivement de l'otan est posée pour
nous pour la france elle a un rôle à
jouer sur la scène internationale qu'est
un rôle de grandes puissances
médiatrices elle ne peut le jouer que si
elle est indépendante et pour ça non
alignés par exemple le mirage de
l'europe de la défense qui est arrimée à
l'otan posent problème et j'insiste sur
le fait que non-alignés ne veut pas dire
neutre quand vladimir poutine choisi la
guerre nous le condamnons nous ne sommes
pas neutres à l'égard de vladimir
poutine adrien quatre mains c'est
l'autre actualité c'est ce rapport du
sénat sur les cabinets de conseil cap
arles qui parle d'un
de neutre entre au grand pardon vos
cours au cabinet de conseil un milliard
pour l'année 2000 21 près d'un milliard
pour l'année 2020 le gouvernement a
expliqué que ce recours au cabinet de
conseil privé est utile il a notamment
justifié sa part la crise sanitaire est
ce que c'est un argument vous entendez
c'est un scandale d'état voilà faut dire
les choses comme elles sont il ya
plusieurs sujets dans un d'abord le
recours accru à ces cabinets de conseils
tout cabinet confondues on est passé à
une multiplication par deux des dépenses
en l'espace d'un quinquennat au total
pour l'ensemble des cabinets c'est plus
d'un milliard et semblablement et puis
quand on regarde dans le détail pas mal
de choses pose question quand on voit
par exemple que le cabinet privé plus
souvent le fait des institutions qui
font doublon avec l'état c'est parce moi
ta montre je te montrerai leur cd
powerpoint bien léché pour montrer
comment on fait mieux avec moins de
moyens mais par exemple bon j'en ai
quelques uns en tête mais boston
consulting group un demi million d'euros
pour l'organisation d'une conférence des
managers de l'état qui n'a jamais eu
lieu bon mc kinsey 4 millions d'euros
pour adapter l'administration à la
baisse des appels ça veut dire qu'en
plus on découvre après que ces gens là
ne payent pas d'impôts donc des cabinets
privés qui ne payent pas d'impôts bref
au total le contribuable se fait plumer
trois fois dans la sphère une première
fois en payant des sommes pharaoniques
pour ces cabinets de conseil une
deuxième fois quand on découvre en
l'occurrence le mc kinsey ne payent pas
d'impôts et une troisième fois quand la
plupart de ses conseils servat a faibli
en au service public et notre protection
sociale totalement se passer des
cabinets de conseil comme le dit jean
luc mélenchon je penserai man et domeo
compétents son nom mais je dire ça
existe et moi pas faire son nombre de
découvrir les cabinets de conseil à la
lumière de ce scandale mais je crois que
nous avons une administration publique
de qualité et que on peut faire avec les
moyens de l'état pour le peu qu'on y
réinvestissant cours si vous êtes élu
durant 25 et c'est ce que nous avons dit
oui en effet
dernière chose même si monsieur macron
visiblement assez fébrile face à cette
situation doit rendre des comptes adrien
4 nages et bien sûr que si on lit bien
sûr moi j'attends la réponse d'emmanuel
macron ce week-end qui dit oh mais les
attributions de marchés publics ça
répond à des règles wild eyes open a
aimé mais je veux dire que les
attributions de marchés publics
répondent à des règles oui que l'on
constate après les règles d'attribution
des marchés publics que tient par le
fruit d'un hasard qui parfois fait très
bien les choses un ami personnel des
manuels macron est chargé des contrats
entre l'état et mckinsey que l'on
découvre par ailleurs que mckinsey a
fait bénéficier aux candidats macro et
peut-être même avant même au ministre de
l'économie c'est ce que dit l'article de
mediapart de prestations gratuites se
poser quand même des questions vous en
connaissez beaucoup vous des
prestataires de services qui sonne chez
vous pour des ravages tient monsieur je
viens repeint de vos murs mais c'est
gratuit cette fois ont très clairement
aucun mandat et même à comprendre des
contres mais oui mais je crois qu'il
n'est pas disposé à le faire visiblement
puisque
mais de toute façon clairement cette
situation enfin si nous étions dans une
démocratie parfaite le scandale mckinsey
sera en mesure d'empêcher le président
de la république d'être candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
voilà on parle quand même de gros
recours à des cabinets privés et de gens
qui ne payent pas d'impôts en france
c'est un scandale absolu peut dire il ya
eu mensonge vraisemblablement devant une
commission parlementaire voilà de quoi
on parle au coeur de l'élection
présidentielle donc je comprends que les
français sont des mensonges vous
expliquer visant à un public pour vous
il ne devrait pas se présenter
aujourd'hui suite à cette affaire bah on
devrait pas de rien de vrai il devrait
pas simplement se cacher derrière l'idée
de l'attribution des marchés publics ça
va au delà de ça et compris sur la
question fiscale et sur le recours accru
enfin pardon mais puisque vous en
reparler mckinsey par exemple avant
d'être choisie en france pour la
campagne vaccinale il avait été condamné
aux états unis parce qu'ils avaient
participé à la campagne de diffusion
d'une molécule qui s'est révélé être une
molécule pour laquelle des
deux personnes ont fait des overdoses et
c'est pas forcément des gens qui sont
partout très recommandable là l'autre
actualité c'est cette remise remise des
prix sur le prix du carburant sur les dj
carburant qui entre en vigueur
aujourd'hui de 15 à 18 centimes sur tout
le territoire est ce que vous
reconnaissez que c'est un bol d'air pour
les automobilistes mais
incontestablement mais très très
insuffisant de dire quand on voit le
niveau de la hausse des prix quand jean
luc mélenchon a commencé à parler
blocage des prix face à l'inflation
c'était 1,40 à la pompe voulait un
blocage à rennes 1-0 maintenant oui et
en fait vous financez commente mais
c'est pas à nous de le financer par cnp
trop d'écart mais c'est à dire que c'est
assez simple si vous voulez bloquer les
prix administrés les prix ça demande
même pas un passage devant le parlement
c'est un décret de code du commerce
voilà à titre d'exemple pourquoi 1,40
pourquoi pas un 30 pourquoi pas un euro
à 1,40 pour une raison simple c'est que
la première fois qu'on a parlé nous de
blocage des prix la première fois qu'on
a assumé ce terme politiquement c'était
1 40 donc imaginez bien que 1 40 ça veut
dire les déjà les bloquer à la baisse et
les ramener à un niveau de prix qui va
soulager beaucoup de monde quoi mais
qu'il est car les pétroliers mais très
simplement oui ces larves est d'après
c'est plus notre sujet c'est aux
pétroliers de 2 comment dire de gérer
cette situation
mais vous croyez franchement attal et
arrêtons nous un instant là dessus qui
est en état quel pétrolier est en état
de refuser un marché de combien 67
millions de personnes pensez franchement
qu'ils vont le faire non par contre
disons les choses est ce que vous savez
de quoi et quelle est la cause de cette
augmentation des prix vous le savez
l'augmentation des prix il est dû à quoi
la spéculation et ben voila merci de le
dire une simple spéculation c'est à dire
qu'il ya les lois de l'offre et la
demande du marché et que l'on pourrait
par exemple les producteurs pourraient
accroître la production pour limiter la
hausse des prix ils ne le font pas donc
ça suffit c'est à dire que on peut pas
avoir des pétroliers qui s'enrichissent
considérablement comme ils l'ont fait à
voir des résultats nets qui sont des
records comme par exemple a pu les
réaliser total et avoir des français
serré à la gorge on parle de gens qu'ils
renoncent à se déplacer on parle
potentiellement de boîtes qui vont
couler donc en fait arrêtons de
considérer que les lois de l'offre et de
la demande et les lois du marché
soumettre sans aucune sans aucune raison
donc oui bloquer les prix c'est valable
pour les sens mais c'est valable aussi
pour un certain nombre de produits de
première nécessité noter par exemple que
à la réunion dans nos outre mer là alors
on se parle le préfet a pouvoir de
bloquer 153 prix et qu'il ya des
conseils citoyens dans lesquels on
établit avec les citoyens la liste des
prix peuvent être administrés alors
qu'elle prive ou black aurait bien nous
par exemple ça concerne les carburants
l'énergie électricité gaz et des
produits de première nécessité
alimentaire et hygiénique voilà c'est à
dire en gros soulager les gens la
question du blocage des prix n'est pas
dans notre programme est une mesure
pérenne c'est une mesure exceptionnelle
pour faire face à la situation liste
publiée le 25 avril honda pouvoir
l'établir l'établir démocratiquement et
collectivement en tout cas c'est clair
le carburant l'électricité le gaz et par
exemple les 5 fruits et légumes a priori
dont on dispose à chaque jour qu'elles
sont qui sont indispensables à la
nourriture et voilà je pense que c'est
une mesure qui doit se faire face à la
montée des prix en revanche une chose
sur le pouvoir d'achat dans le programme
là d'autres mesures qui l
on va rester sur le pouvoir d'achat rien
qu'à tenace à ce que vous proposez une
augmentation du smic net à 1400 euros
par décret la notamment qu'est ce que
vous dites c'est aux chefs d'entreprise
pour le coup de payer parce que ces
autos pétrolier d'assurer les prix
bloqués soit c'est tout chef
d'entreprise ou patrons aux petites
entreprises aux grandes d'assumer cette
hausse du smic alors il ya deux choses à
dire je vais commencer par dire la plus
rassurante pour ceux qui vraiment s'en
inquiète c'est que évidemment
l'augmentation des salaires
l'augmentation du smic elle va avoir un
effet
en termes de cotisations sociales et
donc il faut que les plus petites
entreprises pme/tpe les artisans soient
accompagnés nous allons donc créer une
caisse de péréquation entre les grandes
entreprises et les petites pour qu'ils
aient une solidarité sur ses cotisations
sociales liées à la hausse du smic
première chose mais la deuxième et qui
va devrait intéresser le plus je crois
les pme les tpe les artisans les
commerçants c'est que évidemment quand
vous augmenter les petits salaires bon à
peu près 100 % de notre augmentation de
salaire elle va dans la consommation
populaire donc ça va dans le circuit
économique la plupart de ses activités
auxquelles vous songez artisans
commerçants locaux d'activités qui ne
sont pas délocalisables qui vont donc
bénéficier les premières de cette
augmentation des salaires voilà et puis
ensuite augmenter les salaires c'est une
question de justice tout simplement
parce que les travailleurs de ce pays
produisent beaucoup et la répartition de
richesses se fait très mal ces dix
dernières années par exemple les
dividendes versés aux actionnaires ont
progressé de 70% quand dans le même
temps les salaires n'augmentaient en
moyenne que de 10 et l'investissement
productif diminué donc ce fut beau
couleurs du capital avec nous c'est
clair ce sera lors du travail du travail
revalorisé par la hausse du smic qui va
bénéficier d'abord à tous les salaires
qui se trouvent autour de 2000 euros et
ensuite des négociations par branches
pour l'augmentation générale des
salaires donc si j'allais plus mais pas
travailler plus mais en fait encore une
fois on entend des mois les français
travaillent déjà bien assez produisent
suffisamment par exemple un travailleur
français aujourd'hui à lui tout seul
produit trois fois plus de richesses cas
travailleurs français 10 à 50 ans donc
réfléchissez un instant si on produit
plus de richesses avec moins de travail
humain mais que les salariés ne voient
pas leur salaire augmenter en proportion
ni leur temps de travail diminue et la
question qui se pose c'est où va
l'argent la réponse vous la connaissez
donc il s'agit de mieux répartir
l'effort et de mieux répartir la
richesse produite sur les retraites vous
êtes pour un retour à la retraite à 60
ans comment vous faites avec un sénat de
droite qui n'en veut pas d'abord on est
avec un peuple de qui le souhaitent à
71% le retour de la retraite à 60 ans
ben on cherche à convaincre voilà et
puis les sénateurs
moi je pense que rien n'est au dessus de
la souveraineté populaire et que si le
peuple français décident le programme où
il ya la retraite à 60 ans c'est ce
programme qui s'appliquera et gérard
écurat des mobilisations populaires non
pas des manifestations comptait mais la
réforme des retraites de monsieur macro
mais du soutien populaire à la réforme
de la retraite à 60 ans comment vous
fait passer la loi mais ça on ne
discutera avec les sénateurs mais le
plus sur le suffrage universel titus
c'est ce qui est important c'est quoi
c'est pas de savoir si les sénateurs
vont bloquer une réforme que souhaite le
peuple français le plus important c'est
de savoir est-ce que c'est sérieux de le
proposer pourquoi et comment on le
finance oui c'est sérieux parce que bon
on ne revient pas sur les discours ont
produit assez de richesse si on produit
trois fois plus qu'il ya 50 ans avec le
même la même niveau de travail mais ça
veut dire qu'on peut donc financé plus
de retraités et de retraite avec le même
niveau en réalité quand monsieur macron
dit vous allez travailler plus longtemps
c'est une autre manière de dire je ne
partagerais pas davantage la richesse
produite jusqu'à présent on connaissait
doit être mesuré ce sera compliqué à
mettre en place absolument part du non
absolument pas je veux dire
techniquement en tout cas c'est facile à
faire je veux dire d'abord rappelé que à
62 ans un quart des hommes les plus
pauvres sont déjà morts que au sein
d'une même génération il ya des écarts
d'espérance de vie considérable c'est
aux six années entre un cadre et un
ouvrier très années entre les 5 % les
plus pauvres les 5% les plus riches on
dit parfois on vit plus longtemps il
faut travailler plus longtemps non c'est
notamment parce qu'on travaille moins
longtemps qu'on vit plus longtemps donc
c'est une question encore une fois de
répartition de l'effort dans ce pays à
mesure que la part des seniors dans la
population progresser on a toujours
consacré plus de richesse au financement
des retraites donc là pour financer la
retraite à 60 ans il nous faut en fait
deux points de plus de la richesse
nationale 2 points de plus du pib' pour
financer la retraite à 60 ans ça peut se
faire par la création d'activités et
d'emplois qui vont remplir les caisses
de cotisation si on fait l'égalité des
femmes et des hommes au niveau salarial
ça permettra de financer la retraite à
60 ans et puis aussi d'augmenter en
proportion là où il ya les gros salaires
les cotisations de manière indolore mais
pour financer la retraite à 60 ans oui
c'est souhaitable il faut le faire et
nous le ferons en tout cas et d'ailleurs
c'est le seul bulletin de vote qui le
permet puisque vous voyez bien que même
madame le pen y'a renoncer peut-être
d'ailleurs qu'il faut le dire ça à
celles et ceux qui nous écoutent
j'entends que depuis que monsieur
zemmour fait toutes les outrances qu'on
lui connaît madame le pen apparaîtrait
comme quelqu'un de the nabeul qui
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs même
s'occuperait des petites gens alors moi
je m'adresse à ces personnes qui pensent
que madame le pen va solutionner leur
problème sur le pouvoir d'achat et tout
le reste madame le pen c'est quelqu'un
qui ne veut pas augmenter les salaires
qui refusent le dégel du point d'indicé
des fonctionnaires alors que les
fonctionnaires ont perdu par ce seul
fait 20% de leur pouvoir d'achat en 20
ans madame le pen refuse le blocage des
prix dont nous avons parlé et elle a
renoncé à la retraite à 60 ans
maintenant renoncer à dire si vous
commencez
pas sans doute
plus tard ça sera 62 donc elle a renoncé
parce qu'avant c'était la retraite à 60
ans pour tous et maintenant c'est la
petite astérix comme dans les contrats
d'assurance vous savez madame le pen a
renoncé donc moi je veux que les gens
l'entendent parce que madame le pen
c'est l'autre candidat des riches son
programme économique c'est du maquereau
nice meurent pas en bleu marine il ya
des gens qui se font berner et ils
doivent l'entendre si vous voulez qu'on
augmente les salaires si vous voulez
qu'on fasse la retraite à 60 ans il faut
voter pour jean luc mélenchon et
d'ailleurs c'est une opportunité les
français en ont par-dessus la tête qu'on
leur fasse le coup du barrage au second
tour bah là on al opportunité historique
de se passer de cette question-là en
chassant dans les urnes l'extrême droite
et le premier juste un mot là-dessus
puisque vous y n'est évidemment vous
êtes porté jean luc mélenchon soit au
second tour la question ce qu'on soit
messimy l'est pas on n'a pas très bien
compris votre position c'est un duel
entre emmanuel macron et marine le pen
qu'est ce que vous direz à vos électeurs
le disais je n'ai pas très bien compris
non on n'a pas très bien compris parce
que jean luc mélenchon dit qu'il va
faire appel à sa base la ce a 310 mille
personnes qui ont voté pour sa
candidature vous vous dites c'est pas
voter pour marine le pen ce n'est pas
une option est ce que clairement le 10
avril vous dirai oui il faut aller voter
pour emmanuel macron non nous ne le
dirons sûrement pas je ne le crois pas
nous dirons comme nous avons dit en 2017
parce que ce n'est pas une option compte
tenu de ce que nous sommes politiquement
c'est à dire l'antithèse de l'extrême
droite sion si nous prendrons position
parce que pardon de vous dire que dira
pas une voix ne doit aller à l'extrême
droite c'est prendre position par contre
ça veut aussi dire peut-être gens qui
vous écoutent dans ces cas-là on
s'abstient mais les gens feront bien ce
qu'ils veulent et je vous le dis pour je
vous dis pourquoi et c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs nous allons consulter la base
pour savoir ce qu'elles ce qu'elle
entend faire mais dans cette
consultation que ce soit bien clair le
vote rassemblement national ne sera pas
une option donc ça sera une
méfiance et leurs rayons paralysants
sinon c'est à dire qu'en gros vous ne
pouvez plus rien faire et quand vous
avez un président de la république
sortant qui vous annoncent un programme
d'une brutalité sociale son nom qui
maintenant veut s'attaquer à l'école
vous avez entendu lire les quelques
fuites qui a eu ce parce que ça vaut
mais moi j'ai entendu pas rancunier une
discussion dans laquelle maintenant la
rémunération des professeurs variable
selon les résultats de leurs élèves les
notes des élèves est en discussion ces
gens là veulent saccagé l'état pardon
mais non on va pas courir d'enthousiasmé
pour dire oh oui c'est le rempart
absolue ces gens là d'ailleurs participé
à la progression de l'extrême droite
dans notre pays à force de casser le la
l'état social que nous avions de notre
modèle de protection sociale c'est eux
qui en réalise et font grimper les
quatre ans comme vous êtes sur l'extrême
droite est ce que vous estimez vous
aussi que comme emmanuel macron marine
le pen était banalisé dont le discours
ambiant sans doute oui sans doute et à
force y compris que un certain personnel
médiatiques parfois 10 à madame le pen a
fait des efforts elle s'est recentré non
moi je juge les les candidats en
politique sur la base de leur programme
pour vous le pen en vous lisant vous
lisez le programme de madame le pen
c'est un programme qui est assez
banalement d'extrême droite sur beaucoup
d'aspects et qui économiquement je le
dis n'est pas très éloigné du maquereau
nisme voilà par exemple madame le pen un
autre exemple qui me vient quand elle
vous dit qu'elle va augmenter vos
salaires puisque elle n'augmente pas le
smic en fait elle vous fait payer vous
même votre propre augmentation de
salaire par la baisse de vos cotisations
sans vous dire qu'après c'est par
l'impôt ou par la contractualisation
d'assurances privées que vous allez
devoir régler le problème donc je crois
vraiment et je le dis que des tas de
debre argent ce qui est des gens qui
croient aux thèses identitaire
ethniciste de l'extrême droite cela ils
sont plus compliquées à convaincre mais
par contre il ya des tas de gens qui
sont ce que nous avons appelé que jean
luc mélenchon les fâcher pas facho des
gens qui sont en colère dans la
situation sociale désastreuse qui pour
une raison qui m'échappe pense que
madame le pen va solutionner leur
problème et ben il faut pied-à-pied leur
dire dites-nous en quoi regardons son
programme et dites nous à quoi il va
améliorer votre sort par contre oui si
vous voulez l'augmentation des salaires
le blocage des prix là vous avez un
candidat qui lui il permet donc un
bulletin de vote qui vaut plus qu'un
enjeu ghazi ont été remis à parler de
votre candidat jean-luc mélenchon un
baromètre doxa qui a été publié
récemment estime que les français ont
une mauvaise opinion jean luc mélenchon
68% des français ont une mauvaise
opinion 63% devant le juge peu honnête
78% le juge impulsif et 70% agressif est
ce qu'il ya un point avec la
personnalité de jean-luc mélenchon est
ce que c'est ça qui peut être le plafond
de verre finalement de la france a
souvent vous savez les personnalité
clivante dont on connaît les
débordements passé vous savez d'abord
bon il ya des sondages y compris sur sa
personnalité qui sont moins sévères que
ségou présenter la dune pas mais ensuite
et une élection présidentielle n'est pas
une opération de séduction la question
qu'on vous pose c'est pas être vous
amoureuse amoureux de jean luc mélenchon
d'accord la question qu'on vous pose
c'est que pensez vous de son programme
c'est là dessus que vous ayez une
question de confiance alors n'attendez
pas la même chose est séduit par un
candidat à avoir confiance en lui c'est
pas la même chose jean luc mélenchon
c'est quelqu'un qui triche pas et qui a
70 ans n'est pas en train de préparer
une carrière et quand il vous dit si
c'est ce programme que vous choisissez
quels que soient les obstacles c'est ce
programme qui s'appliquera crois que les
français ont des raisons de prendre au
sérieux et je le confirme parce que si
nous sommes élus c'est ce que nous
ferons et nous l'appliquerons et nous
anticipons même les obstacles qui
pourraient se dresser devant
l'application ce programme c'est la
souveraineté populaire qui au-delà tous
et pardon de vous dire que un candidat
d'expérience comme jean luc mélenchon sa
troisième candidature à la
présidentielle en effet quand vous allez
dans des quartiers populaires dont nous
avons besoin de la mobilisation parce
que l'abstention on en parlait juste
avant que votre invité c'est un risque
or notre sort il est celle au niveau de
la participation d'accor dans les
quartiers populaires et que nous dit
jean luc mélenchon les gens savent de
qui on parle ce qui n'est pas le cas de
tous les candidats mais ils savent ce
qu'on a l'intention de faire merci ça va
arrêter notre
la france a soumis ce porte parole du
candidat jean luc mélenchon line le
sudes l affaire des toons habito ni
intoxication en séries c'était la une de
votre journal on
[Musique]